[Music]
everyone Bonnie made a friend in class
oh she's already making friends
no no she literally made a new friend I
want you to meet
porky he's a spool yes yeah I know
porky is the most important toy to
Bonnie right now we all have to make
sure nothing happens to it woody we have
a situation I am NOT a toy I was they
pursue salad maybe chili and then the
trash but we gotta get four key
affirmative
why am i alive
you're Bonnie's toy you are going to
help create happy memories that will
last for the rest of her life huh oh hi
there my name is Gabby Gabby
we can't stay yes you can boys what are
you doing here no time to explain
come with me we need to get back to our
kids Oh Sheriff woody always come in to
the rescue Bonnie needs four key woody
who needs a kids room when you can have
all them yes Wow
woody aren't we going to Bonnie jump out
of a moving vehicle let's go
yeah gotta go you gotta go
[Music]
you know you've handled this lost toy
life better than I could open your eyes
woody there's plenty of kids out there
sometimes change can be good you can't
teach this old toy new tricks you'd be
surprised
Bonnie we're going home working
[Music]
[Music]
kids lose their toys every day I was
made to help the child to remember it
being this part ready somebody's
whispering in your ear
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what generations this peaceful island
has been home to our family beyond our
great danger is coming legend tells of a
hero who journey to find that demigod
Maui hero of men it's actually Maui
shapeshifter demigod of the women sea
hero of men I interrupt it from the top
hero of men go going on a mission with
some little girls is my canoe and you
did not see that coming ocean a friend
of mine first we've got to go through a
whole ocean of bad they're kind of cute
[Applause]
[Music]
got your back
it's Maui
really blow dart in my butt cheek we're
going to the realm of monsters don't
worry it's a lot farther down than it
looks
[Music]
[Applause]
okay seriously dad Walken would have
been fine
breaking news spider-man saves the day I
guess spider-man this guy swings in once
the day zip zap zop dancing guys don't
cops run red lights well some do but uh
not your dad in your universe there's
only one spider-man but there's another
universe it looks this sounds like yours
but it's not my name is Miles Morales
like me around this time I know it's
complicated
I know what happened to you I can teach
you to be spider-man you have money
right I'm not very liquid right now I
think you're gonna be a bad teacher how
am I supposed to save the whole world
you can't think about saving the world
you have to think about saving one
person one thing I know for sure don't
do it like me do it like you
[Music]
I see the sparking it's amazing paired
up whatever you choose to do it that
you'll be great
I love you miles you gotta say I love
you back I want to hear it you want to
hear look at this dad I love you Oh God
just like I thought when did you teach
me that I didn't it's a little joke the
team-building hey guys okay
who are you i'm gwen stacy people are
there same as a comic-con
what's the lose the greatest musician of
all time I want to be just like him
[Music]
you will visit to your family if I wanna
be a musician
I gotta seize my moments Senor de la
Cruz help me follow my dream
[Music]
you know where we are
Nikki what is going on remind me how I
know you
doesn't have any hair and I don't have a
nose and yet here we are we don't get
you home before sunrise you'll be stuck
here forever it's not leaving boy but
first I need to find this nestled in a
booth I can help you
[Music]
it's show time
I'm a big man you mind if I
[Music]
[Applause]
my whole life there's something that
made me different one cannot deny who
one is meant to be sunrise now you must
make a choice
what are you doing walking like a
skeleton
randilynn no skeletons don't walk like
that it's how you walk no I don't stop
it
[Music]
summer in the city of arendelle couldn't
be warmer but that's about to change
forever
snow you want to talk about a problem I
sell ice for a living that's unfortunate
hi everyone I'm Olaf your creepy we got
off to a bad start
whoa get your feet down seriously were
you raised in a barn
are you got a thick skull I don't have a
skull
[Music]
oh you're melting some people are worth
melting for it they just move you're not
right this circus
[Music]
those are my legs oh oh the dais star
fell it was almost like might seem
something out of a dream nothing more or
less than a breathtaking view
[Music]
last ello you open your eyes but even a
Pacific a failure
thanks but I gotta go to work
it's too small
[Music]
[Applause]
in some strange reason
we could dream about
[Music]
dreams that grow night for switching
braces
[Applause]
there's one thing I'm certain
did we see each other we'll definitely
know right away
I wanted to tell you wherever you are
nor I swear that I'll find you again
[Music]
Zootopia a gleaming city where animals
of all breeds predator and prey alike
live together in peace and harmony CPD's
first rabbit officer Judy Hopps ready to
make the world better place bad news in
this city gripped by fear what can you
tell us about the animals have been
savaged are we safe this is Priority One
ops parking duty sir I'm not just some
token bunny you strike out you resign
deal I'm here to ask you some questions
back then they should have gotten a real
cop to solve it we're under arrest for
what hurting your feelings you are a key
witness no he is hey I need you to run a
plate all right I know a guy you need
something done he's on it they're all
slots
we are in a really big hurry I am on
it's break I have 36 hours left we can
only solve it together it's not about
how bad do you want something it's about
what you are capable I am a real cop
never let them see that they get here
you bunny is so emotional maybe a love
but deep down we're still animal for
sure we're a naturalist Club down
[Music]
[Applause]
life's a little bit messy we all make
mistakes no matter what type of animal
you are chain starts with you we gotta
go skies the most feared crime boss mr.
bean
[Music]
and put on your church shoes little
sister cuz we're about to blast off what
is it you're trying to say we're going
the Internet
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
what can I help you find today umbrella
Umbria mommy no no is that no doubt no
it's from Reaganomics
cool pretty sure he's just trying to
guess what you're gonna say my auto feel
is to touch aggressive today let me try
take me to a website that's super
intense and really nuts oh I only found
one result
[Music]
I'm a princess too what kind of a
princess are you oh do you have magic
hair no magic hands
no do animals talk to you no no cursed
no kidnap to enslave no are you guys
okay please do people assume all your
problems got solved because a big strong
man showed up the internet Rex the
Internet yes and he is wreckit-ralph
yeah but break the internet it's like a
thing right it's just wrecking it kind
of sounds better doesn't jumping-jacks
hit him 1 2 3 I am so pumped up yes
overpriced coffee that's 37 dollars
[Music]
where am I
come with me if you want to not die and
the prophecy states that you're the most
important person in the universe that's
you right yes that's me relax everybody
I'm here why are you here to see I'm
here to see your bud first try
my fellow master-builders Lord business
plans to end the world as we know it
there is yet one hope the special has
arisen I know what you're thinking he is
the least qualified person to lead us
and you are right a house divided
against itself would be better than this
I'm not the special I'm just a regular
normal guy you have the ability to be
the special because I believe in you
[Applause]
robots destroy him
[Music]
we'll wing it it's a bad pun come to the
melting chamber isn't there supposed to
also be a good cop
hi buddy would you like a glass of water
yeah actually too bad your mind what I
don't think he's ever had an original
thought that's not true introducing the
double-decker couch so everyone could
watch TV together and be buddies that
was literally the dumbest thing I've
ever heard let me handle this that idea
is just the worst instinct inside you
that feels so familiar that have to
listen to it oh my mom my dad I have a
family we will never forget you
I miss them you know what that feels
like
[Music]
not a great swimmer I think you swim
beautifully yes story yes friends no it
was so much fun cuz I tell you a story
and then you'd completely forget about
it and I get to tell it over again sorry
I got a blink how do you hold your eyes
open that long
[Music]
hello hi can you help me did you wash
your hands with soap did you dry them
all vegetables who ordered all vegetable
I did
so are we going to talk about it what
the elephant in the room what elephant
mom's new job
it's time to make some wrong things
right how they bring supers back into
the sunlight
need to change people's perceptions
about superheroes and Elastigirl is our
best play better than me I'll watch the
kids no problem
not the way you're supposed to do a dad
they wants to do it I don't know that
way why would they change math math is
bad hey honey
everything's great
[Music]
and Jack Jack he's in excellent health
cooking that is freaky you know it's
crazy right to help my family I gotta
leave it to fix the law I gotta break it
you got to before kids can have that
choice thank you young man
combustion imminent what does that mean
it means fire Robert
the screen slider interrupts this
program for important my mouse
it might get weird I'll be there ASAP
[Music]
so how was the first day of school it
was fine I guess
hmm do you ever look at someone and
wonder what is going on inside their
head did you guys pick up on that
something's wrong we're gonna find out
what's happening but we'll need support
signal the husband oh she's looking at
us
what did she say well oh sorry sir no
one's listening is it garbage night we
left the toilet seat up what what is it
woman what signal him again
ah so Riley how was school for this we
gave up that Brazilian helicopter pilot
school was great all right what was that
you said we were gonna act casual Riley
is everything okay sir she just rolled
her eyes that is all right make a show
of force I don't want to have to put the
foot down
no not the foot Riley I do not like this
new attitude oh just leave me alone sir
reporting high levels of sass take it to
DEFCON two get bone to I don't know
where this disrespectful attitude came
from yeah prepare the foot keys the
safety position waiter the lunch on your
command sir
that's it go to your room put us down
the foot is down
good job Jolin that could have been a
disaster
well that was a disaster come fly with
me gatinha the japanese archipelago' 20
years in the future
canine saturation has reached epidemic
proportions an outbreak of dog flu
ripped through the city of Mecca sake
mayor Kobayashi issues emergency orders
calling for a hasty quarantine trash
island becomes an exiled colony the Isle
of Dogs I don't think I can stomach any
more of this garbage here words on my
mouth nobody's giving up around here and
don't you forget it ever your ex your
king your Duke your boss I'm chief we're
a pack of scary indestructible alpha
dogs Atari Kobayashi you heroically
hijacked a junior turboprop XJ 750 and
flew it to the islands because of the
dog
darn it I've got a crush on you we get
the idea you were looking for your lost
dog spots
does anybody know sparks if he's alive
may very well be living even at this
moment as a captive prisoner somebody is
up to something will you help him
the little pilot why should I because
he's a 12 year old boy dogs love those
we'll find him wherever he is if he's
alive we'll find your dog it's gonna be
a fight
[Music]
where somebody spoke his language
to the north a long rickety causeway
over noxious sludge marsh leading to a
radioactive landfill polluted by toxic
chemical garbage that's our destination
right get ready to jump
[Music]